[Musique]
ouf la nous voilà tout de même arriver
nous avions très peur d'être en retard
aujourd'hui car nous avions encore
beaucoup d'autres petits enfants à voir
avant vous mais fort heureusement les
vendeuses ont été très favorables
avez vous été très sage aujourd'hui oui
eh bien j'en suis très content petit
louis et sa soeur mirabel ont eux aussi
étaient très mignons et pour les
récompenser gros ours leur a préparé un
joli je re très haut niveau je peux y
aller patron tu peux y aller nounours et
tuent les embrassera bien fort de ma
part je peux compter sur moi patron hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop on
gentil a dit il du jeu avec moi kachkar
bien chat perché go non je vous ai
préparé un autre jeu beaucoup plus
amusant haha
voilà mon mouchoir rouge pâle rhume
on va jouer à colin maillard les enfants
commençaient
c'est drôle pour sûr c'est drôle on se
cache les yeux avec le mouchoir de la
tâche
ouais et il faut essayer d'attraper les
autres attendez c'est pas tout quand on
attrape quelqu'un il faut le reconnaître
sans le regarder mais seulement en le
touchant à les toucher
oui oui j'ai compris via lattea oui
approche voilà voilà
oui oui c'est nous voyons pour bon bon
bon
[Musique]
qui c'est qui commence c'est toi le news
mais si tu m'avais mettre le foulard la
wiimote ou soulager tout c'est bien cool
non attention légèrement ce nom se cache
au hula la houlala ou ouhlala la voix
j'ai la tête qui tournait
j'y vois rien rien rien
bédard a au nom c'est une serre où
poussent cette fois je te tue heureux
qui sait où ça pique
mais c'est un ballet
cette fois c'est acheter je les attrape
attend des coquins
[Musique]
alors les enfants le jeu vous a plu ah
voilà nounours qui revient je laisse à
cette fois ils ne peuvent pas aller plus
loin à taux plein j'en tiens voyons voir
lequel s'est pas petit louis ce pas non
plus mirabel mais qui ces dons c'est
unissent le marchand de sable à l'on
enlève son bandeau se vouent patron oui
et il tombe bien attrapé mon pauvre ni
go sport oui je suis un gros nigaud vous
pouvez le dire
alors en route nigaud boni les enfants
allez vite vous coucher à demain à
thomas
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
oh